one of the things that I notice about
you or my observation of you is that
you've had many Transformations I feel
like you really have through different
phases of your life everything from uh
how you grew up and not you know
claiming to be an entrepreneur to
um being having addiction to being an
endurance athlete to having a successful
podcast now books and it's like you are
like top of the list for people that
have had so many magnificent
Transformations and have so many stories
so it's definitely your turn to tell the
story of of how you were able to do that
and what I mean I guess I'm really
curious about what what allows you to be
able to move from one phase to another
phase and was it effort or is that
something that actually comes natural
not not everything's easy but that is
seemingly from an observational
standpoint very much part of your life
yeah well I appreciate that observation
Danica I mean I I don't I'm not sure
exactly how to dive into this I I would
say that the changes and the
Transformations that I've endured in my
life are generally uh catalyzed by some
kind of pain point you know where where
the pain of my current uh situation
exceeded the fear of doing something
different and that has typically been my
motivator and I've gone Kicking and
Screaming into all of these
Transformations none of it was graceful
linear or or overnight it's you know
when you kind of look at it in the rear
view mirror me now being an older person
it all kind of looks like it unfolded
very naturally and gracefully but you
know the lived experience of that was
very different but you know as a result
of of having to change or being
compelled to change because of pain has
taught me a few things about the nature
of change itself and you know that began
with my struggle with alcoholism and
ultimately getting sober and you know
learning tools for a different way of
living which you know I think opened me
up to the possibility a that you know I
could change and if I could change other
people could change and as a result of
my participation in the recovery
Community being witness being witness to
so many people changing their lives in
miraculous ways and then understanding
that you know change isn't a static
thing like we have to continue to grow
and iterate like there is no stasis
there's no sitting on our Laurels and
you know yes I have you know weathered
that experience and overcome it but what
are the other areas of my life that
remain hidden or that I don't want to
look at that you know require redress
and ultimately some level of
transformation and I've kind of you know
repeated that time and time again like
from addiction issues to transferring
addiction issues shoes onto workaholism
and my relationship with food and my
relationship with my physical self like
all of those have gone undergone you
know massive Transformations over the
years but this process still continues
like now I'm a parent and I have teens
that have their own issues and you know
there's many times where I feel at a
complete loss as a parent as to how to
you know help these younger people or
parent them or guide them in the best
way possible and that provides an
opportunity for me to have people on the
podcast tell me how to do this you're
the expert
Etc so
you know as they say in the parlance of
recovery the road gets narrower and you
know the the kind of more you grow the
less tolerant you are of other aspects
of how you behave uh that you know
ultimately you can't sleep at night
until you look at them and uh you know
so that's sort of been the approach to
all of it but it's not like I wake up in
the morning and I'm like what am I going
to change today I'm so excited like I
hold on tightly to you know my my you
know errant Behavior patterns of which
there are still many
because it's easier I mean like human
nature is to repeat patterns I think
that's like we're programmed to repeat
the patterns that are instilled into us
and so I think maybe the way to uh get
more focused and help people is
explaining the process of a
transformation first of which is that
you don't want it right like because the
transformation is going to be hard like
I would say like lessons are not meant
to be easy you know their their lessons
are hard and so maybe first what are the
signs like as you've been through so
many different phases of this have you
been able to
become more uh aware and conscious of
getting to a certain point where you're
like these things start happening when I
know that I need to grow yeah I mean
that's a huge subject matter I mean I
guess I would begin by
saying that you know we all do things
that we know are not moving Our Lives
forward like we know when we're spending
too much time scrolling on our phone
that we probably would be happier and
more productive if we were doing
something else and yet we keep doing it
right that would be a you know very
relatable example of that so the first
step in making change is is is is is
simply awareness like okay this is a
problem
um
and you know kind of snapping out of the
denial that like it's fine you know I
could keep doing this and really getting
honest with yourself to say I know that
I would be a happier more productive
person if I could shed this particular
thing that is holding me back so you
know self-awareness key self-honesty
super important and then I think the
first step
of of of of really approaching that
change is asking for help and not trying
to do it yourself like regardless of
what the nature of the problem is like
because I think once you confide in
another human being that you have a
problem and that you would like help
suddenly no longer it's this private
thing that's living inside of you you
have publicly announced it or
semi-publicly announced it and I think
that's huge because now it's out there
and there's sort of a release or a
catharsis with just admitting it like
that's why you know you when you go into
an AAA meaning you raise your hand and
you say you know my name's rich and I'm
an alcoholic like you are making a
public Declaration of a problem that
requires a redress so I think that's
huge
and then
you know with the trusted people with
whom you've confided this problem
I think the key the absolute key beyond
anything else in making a change is
willingness the willingness to do
something different and the willingness
to not only ask for help but to accept
help so when that trusted Confidant says
well why don't you do this instead of
retorting with all the reasons why
that's a bad idea and you know how to
solve it just saying okay and then doing
it and getting into action even if those
actions are tiny like uh maybe I'll
reduce my phone consumption you know 20
percent or whatever they don't have to
be massive gigantic gestures like I'm
gonna throw my phone in the ocean and
never use a cell phone again like those
tend to be you know losing propositions
over the Long Haul and what you're
really trying to do is establish a new
behavioral pattern that will withstand
the test of time and be sustainable so
the sustainable change happens with tiny
iterations that you know little
behavioral tweaks that you master and
become kind of rote in your experience
over time and the big changes that you
seek really are a function of tiny
little things that you do repeatedly
consistently over extended periods of
time that's how you move the needle on
on anything frankly yeah I think I think
that's what James Clear says in atomic
habits it's like you think that it's
like all of a sudden one thing happens
and then oh there it is but it's
actually been all of the little things
that you've done over and over and over
again so many times and then all of a
sudden things do change but you but it
can look like it it wasn't that but it
does take that commitment to it so
what's the
what's the shittiest part
like I think this is where for me
transformation and growth and like I
feel like it's important for people to
just know that there is a really really
shitty part like there's a there's a
there's per whether it's emotionally or
in your immediate reality with people
where you live your job whatever like
there can be there there usually is in
my experience anyway the bigger the
transformation usually it comes with a
package that is like wow this is a lot
right now this is a very overwhelming
amount of stuff but I think that that
talking about the what I would call it
like the Alchemy or the the burning down
of something so something else can be
born and and grow new from it is
important for people to understand has
that been your experience too well yeah
you can't you can't be a phoenix unless
you burn first right you gotta right in
the Flames that's what this is kind of
emerge with a greater wisdom right but I
think the thing is Danica I mean frankly
I think it all sucks it's terrible like
there's nothing like sexy or romantic
about like trying to make a change it's
a very difficult uncomfortable you know
inelegant thing and I you know to the
extent that the internet paints it as
you know something that's that's easy or
that can be accomplished you know
without discomfort I think is a
disservice to people I think it is
important to tell people like yeah it
[ __ ] sucks it's really hard like the
reason it's hard is because whatever
you're doing whether it's gambling or
you keep getting into the you know the
same bad relationship or you know you
drink too much or whatever you know the
change is that you're trying to make
it's important to understand that that
behavior exists for a reason and the
reason is it's serving a purpose like
it's either taking you out of the the
the discomfort of the moment or it's a
reflection of you know know a childhood
trauma or it's a behavioral pattern that
got cemented very early in life that
makes you feel secure and in control
whatever the nature of it the truth
remains that you're doing it for a
reason and that reason is because it is
serving you it may be creating chaos in
your life as well but it is comforting
you in a certain way and when you ask
that person look you got to stop doing
that or the person decides like I can't
do this anymore you're asking them to
break up with with a with a good friend
right they're having to they have to
like part ways with this thing that has
been a comfort blanket for them for a
very long and so the early days of of
you know navigating letting go of that
is almost a morning and it's super
painful and it's really uncomfortable
and there will be many moments where you
know you're going to want to go back to
it or the discomfort of having to really
confront the challenging emotions that
start coming up when you don't have that
comfort blanket can be completely
overwhelming and it's why mastering a
change or overcoming an addiction can be
so difficult and you know I use I don't
use the word Addiction cavalierly like I
think addiction really lives on a
spectrum so on the far end of that
Spectrum you have you know the hardcore
alcoholic or the heroin addict Etc but
you know I think that we all live
somewhere along this spectrum because
we're all engaging in behaviors that we
know are not a reflection of our higher
self and yet we can't seem to stop doing
them and you know and and they're not
making our lives better they're making
our lives worse and that's the classic
definition of of addiction
[Music]
foreign
[Music]